It's been 30 days since Uranus first appeared in the sky.
At first,
it looked like our moon had found itself a stellar partner,
but then we understood something.
Thing much, much bigger was.
Edit our way.
Caused Uranus to become so unstable.
How could this Epic collision change the ice giant? Oh,
and what's this terrific sting.
This.
Is what if, and here's what would happen if Uranus collided with.
Earth.
Let's roll back 30 days when things were still normal,
Uranus lived a quiet life on the outskirts of our solar system,
about 3 billion kilometers away from us.
And then suddenly it began to move closer.
Astronomers.
Would be the first to push the panic button by their calculations.
It would take Uranus 13 years to reach the collision point.
We'd be short on time,
but at least we'd have a slight chance to evacuate the earth,
but the cold blue giant had other plans in mind.
This would be no standard planetary drill planets.
Don't just take off from their orbits for no reason at all.
But somehow Uranus did.
Now it would be hurdling through the solar system ramping up to a speed of
around 1000 kilometers per second,
because of this unexpectedly fast speed we'd only have about
30 days left on this planet.
Uranus would shine like a bright blue star in the sky.
And every day it would appear bigger and brighter.
Our sky would look gorgeous,
not only because of the ice giant shining down on us,
but also thanks to many shooting stars.
Only those wouldn't be stars at all
to get to the Earth's orbit.
Uranus would have to pass an asteroid belt between Jupiter and Mars.
This would disrupt the stable orbits of many asteroids and throw
some of them are away.
These asteroids can be as big as 240 kilometers in
diameter.
That's a few times larger than the one responsible for wiping
dinosaurs off the face of the earth. About 65 million years ago,
we would have nowhere to go.
We'd just be left here watching the end of times,
unfold in front of our eyes might as well enjoy the view
by the time the first to asteroids appeared as shooting stars,
Uranus would look about the same size as the moon,
but it would be growing rapidly as it moved ever closer.
While you'd be here awaiting humanity's doom,
Uranus would start shaking things up because
Uranus is about 15 times more massive than the earth
its gravitational pole would start massively affecting our planet.
Volcanoes would begin erupting uncontrollably and tremendous
earthquakes would get in on the act, destroying the earth from the inside
and the stink you drop unconscious from even
one width of it because, well, I mean,
Uranus smells like farts. The ice giants,
upper atmosphere is mostly composed of hydrogen sulfide.
It's the same stuff that makes rotten eggs rink so bad.
Imagine an entire planet of rotten eggs and golfing the earth.
The thought of it makes me nauseous,
but Uranus wouldn't come alone.
It would bring all of its 27 moons along for the ride.
And those moons would be hitting the earth from all sides.
As a fun-filled filled finale,
Uranus would compress what was left of our atmosphere and the
rapidly rising temperatures would ignite it,
just like that.
Our beautiful blue planet would fall in line and start circling the
ice giant eventually becoming one of its many
moons Uranus wouldn't get away with this assault
so easily. However,
last time it collided with another planetary object twice the size of earth it
tipped over. Yeah,
Uranus is the only planet in our neighborhood. That's spins on it.
Side.
This impact featuring our earthly home could help tilt it back to
how it once was,
but where the earth we know that would be it if by
some unexplained mystery life on earth, stinking,
leftovers emerged. Once again,
we would see the blue of Uranus on the horizon.
It would look just as cool as if the earth was one of Jupiter's moons,
but that's a story for another, what is.